se votará por rusia unida por supuesto
que no estos activistas opositores hacen
un sondeo para su blog que piensa de
rusia en vida y en nueve si ha venido a
responder esa pregunta es provocadora
siente miedo la mayoría de los
encuestados son contrarios o rechazan al
partido programado de bing abrazó la
opinión pública cambiar radicalmente
debido a la reforma de las pensiones y
las enmiendas a la constitución
e incluso los subsidios pre electorales
muchos los han visto como un soborno por
la pensión de olga se ha ido
transformando en un complemento a otros
trabajos debido a la reforma no podrá
acceder a ella hasta dentro de ocho años
participó somos como mendigos compramos
todo en promoción consumimos productos
caducados porque están rebajados con
este panorama hoy otra olga ya es ex
partidaria del presidente vladimir putin
durante mucho tiempo lo vi todo de color
de rosa pero poco a poco dejé de verlo
así y la gota que colmó el vaso fue la
reforma de las pensiones miren nuestras
provincias la gente está absorta en la
miseria y el alcohol porque no tienen
trabajo
[Música]
estás jubiladas en cambio apoyan al
partido del kremlin
[Música]
creo que todos los integrantes del
partido todos todos son personas que
hacen mucho para el país y que hacen por
usted por el país
por nosotros yo pienso que nos gusta es
todo y últimamente algunas personas
están decepcionadas porque esperaron
cambios aún mejores pero el
perfeccionismo es el enemigo del éxito
parte de la ciudadanía está harta de la
estabilidad de putin sin embargo el
escrutinio no les ofrecerá un cambio